I will appoint a real special prosecutor
to go after the most corrupt president
of the history of the United States of
America Joe Biden
and the entire Biden crime family
name a special prosecutor
people in the background are yelling
lock him up about Joe Biden these are
the people who claim Trump wasn't given
due process and they want Biden locked
up absent forget about an indictment
absent any evidence of Criminal Intent I
will totally obliterate the Deep State
we will obliterate
so Trump going conspiratorial but if you
are on the right and you are claiming
that we are a Banana Republic because
Trump was indicted Trump is straight up
saying we're gonna go after the bidens
period full stop no due process no
evidence